يعجز البعض عن خساره الوزن فيلجا قسم منهم
الى الحلول الجراحيه واحيانا الى العقاقير
الطبيه لا سيما ادويه السكر التي وصفها
المروجون بالتخسيس السحري ولكن انتبهوا
قبل اتخاذ القرار تحذيرات عالميه تطالب
ثلاثه عقاقير مضاده لمرض السكري اشتهرت
بعلاجها ايضا للبدانه غير المرغوب بها الا
ان وكاله الادويه الاوروبيه تطلب التريث
قليلا خاصه وانها تدرس 150 حاله محتمله
يعتقد بان كل من استخدم هذه الحقن التي
تبطئ وصول الطعام الى المعده وتسد الشهيه
راودته فكره الانتحار او ايذاء النفس بعد
اعتماد وصفه طبيه تشمل احد العقاقير
المشتبه بها اوزنبك وساكسيندا
فان استسهال هذه الادويه كوسيله سريعه قد
تصاحبه اضغاث افكار الانتحاريه ليبقى خيار
الرياضه او اتباع حميه غذائيه الطريقه
الاسلم والافضل للتخلص من السمنه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات